[Music]
foreign watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin McGuire and the
sun's political reporter Noah Hoffman
welcome and good evening to both of you
so let's see what's on the front pages
then the guardian leader with Joe
Biden's promise of six billion dollars
in U.S government funding to be given to
Northern Ireland if power sharing at
Stormont is restored that story also
making the front of the eye the headline
Biden appeals for stormwatch
breakthrough as the U.S denies he is
anti-british
confirming Prince Harry's attendance at
the coronation The Daily Mirror says the
spare will be there
Harry's blink and you miss it coronation
visit is on the front page of the Daily
Mail
the telegraph also covers the Duke's
decision saying his appearance could
spark hopes for a royal truce similarly
the king's relief that Harry will be
there is the focal point for the Daily
Express whereas the sun focuses more
closely on the duchess's absence the
King was there for you the paper rights
so sad you can't make it for him the
Metro hears that the broadcasting
regulator ofcom has received more than a
thousand complaints about the channel
for program naked education which is
before the nine o'clock Watershed and
features full frontal nudity the
financial time says the bank of England
Governor Andrew Bailey is considering
reforming the bank deposit Insurance
guarantee scheme aimed at making sure
smaller Banks don't fail and on a far
different note the start tells us that
penguin excrement could help save the
planet but there isn't enough of it or
them by the look of it a reminder by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us but let's
head straight now to our guests Kevin
McGuire and Noah Hoffman um get out to
Harry's attendance in just a moment but
first of all to the Biden visit Kevin
you kick us off if you can and first of
all obviously in Northern Ireland
democracy needs Champion is he made a
bid for parties to to return to Stormont
how's it gone so far do you reckon
I have probably uh predictably with some
Loyalists and unionists very much
against him accusing of being anti
British issues have to respond to that
but most people seem to have greeted him
quite uh quite warmly I don't think
there's any breakthrough moment but you
can see from the guardian that this idea
of holding out Prosperity if there is
peace and increasing the uh the amount
of U.S investment uh in in Northern
Ireland is is certainly a carrot that
should be attractive to many people who
are query the query the figures tripling
is six billion from two billion dollars
that two believe was over uh over the
past decade I just wonder when the the
other four billion would go in and what
real guarantee is there it would be
delivered where most of it would be the
private sector but no he's it's kind of
a bit it's a bit shaky because he has
seen he's Irish he's proud of his Irish
Roots he's a Catholic so part of the
community in Northern Ireland is just
going to be wary of him not to see a
hostile
um you know bring in the idea that the
White House had denied that he's
anti-british he certainly spent the
first part of his speech at um the
Ulster University campus in Belfast Noah
explaining that his family had Huguenot
roots and that they came from Nottingham
you know it tried to establish he had a
bit of British or English in him as well
I suppose
um so it's not you know the pro the
fears for the unionists of course is
that he's a Republican president
um so how did the hat to deny his
anti-british come about
heritage age and his Catholic Irish
heritage as well which has worried as
Kevin pointed out some unionists and so
obviously he was very keen to stress
that he is an anti-british and to sort
of relay any underlying fears of some
unionist MPS and some Tory MPS of what
as well who was behind the scenes been
saying that they don't think this visit
is helpful and that they don't think
Biden
um is going there in good faith for all
parties involved but I wouldn't
necessarily agree with that I don't
think he is anti-british and I think he
um just needed to make that very clear
because of some gassies made in the past
and and Richie sunac was very
um clear and confident that Biden was
visiting the province you know in good
faith and that what both leaders want to
see is the resumption of power sharing
however that looks very unlikely to
happen in the near future yes and
watching uh pictures of their with with
the uh the deputy leader Michael Martin
at uh carlingford Castle the suggestion
of course is that was the last few of
his great great grandfather Owen
Finnegan who left during the uh the
Irish famine in 1849 for a new life in
the United States and uh his relative
Owen Finnegan would have stared back at
the castle as he Departed the shores but
a great picture in the financial times
as well Kevin of the lead role as he
puts it the U.S President Joe Biden
embracing James Martin who starred in
the recent Oscar when he filmed an Irish
goodbye during his visit to Northern
Ireland yesterday but it was brief that
Northern Ireland visit wasn't it very
brief blinking you miss it we heard
about the uh the Harry visit for the
coronation you could almost say the same
for for the bit in Northern Ireland
today
no I think that's right it was really
toe touching wasn't it about half the
was it 15 to 16 hours half of that he's
spent in his hotel uh you know in in bed
so it wasn't quick in and out to Mark
The Good Friday agreement and because he
wants to get get over the board anyway
you could be pro-irish doesn't make you
Auntie British but he wants to go over
the over the board the the Republic of
Ireland where his family's from he has
those ties and back home 40 million
Irish Americans or or so it's great for
for votes with a presidential election
coming up that's what it's really about
yeah it's it's about a good Friday
agreement it's about the Republic of
Ireland but it's also about winning a
presidential election next year and
showing the Irish voters back home
you're popular in Ireland you understand
them You've Got Roots like them come and
vote for me that's what it is all about
it's a campaign Trail now and he was
greeted uh enthusiastically I think
those shouting at him in uh Northern
Ireland in the sense of saying he's
Auntie Bridge they're a minority even in
Northern Ireland they're not they're not
the they're not the majority by uh by
any means so I I think you'll feel it's
gone pretty well so far although he
slightly knocked off course from having
to say like I'm not only an anti-british
which is just a utterly ludicrous
accusation yes well it was picked up by
the eye isn't it Biden appeals for
stormwatch breakthrough as the U.S
denies he's anti-british and the paper
goes on to say that the eye has been
told of the fear uh within UK government
ranks that the trip risks alienating
unionists and certainly we heard from
the shin Fein president today Mary Lou
McDonald suggesting that she believed
within the next decade there would be a
poll on uh the unification of Ireland
and for the dup and other unionist
parties therefore Noah
um you need you kind of get a sense of
why they they this is sort of an
existential threat as far as they are
concerned
yeah of course they would be extremely
worried about any sort of sentiment
expressed by such a powerful leader um
you know no less than the US president
that he may have sympathies uh with one
side that goes against everything they
believe in and everything they spend you
know every day fighting for but as Kevin
said um I really don't think that he is
anti-british or that he is
um deeply personally partisan
um in the matter in fact he's stressed
many times that
um you know how um grateful he is for
the Good Friday agreement how much he
values it and how much he wants to see
Power sharing back up again he hasn't
hinted at taking any sort of side in any
hypothetical future poll on um
reunification so I've I understand the
worries because rhetoric you know is you
need to be very careful with what you
say
um in this area of politics but I think
there could be some you know um overly
sensitive thoughts around that from some
people well a packed a program of events
for the president on Thursday full
coverage of course of that but let's
move on to the strikes and a phrase or a
title we've not heard for a while uh the
arbitration service a cast I had to
explain it to some of our younger
producers I feel like I'm getting old
Kevin has to be said anyway the point
being that Junior doctors leaders have
asked for the conciliation service a
cast to break the deadlock with the
government in The Rao of a pay does this
take us back to the 70s or the 80s or
was it the 90s I can't remember
all three all three I used to spend many
years as a journalist outside acass
where peace talks would I uh peace hopes
would rather would either rise or fall
in whatever the negotiations uh were
staying until the early hours of the
morning both sides would break up then
they'd resume and God I tell you it was
pretty miserable at uh at times because
you didn't have anywhere to go for
anything to eat or drink or go to the
toilet but um I think it's a it's a
smart move by the British Medical
Association to say look Let's Get Away
Cass uh I would have thought PR wise if
nothing else the government should
accept and say look we may require a
mediator here the the honest broker the
vacas back in the news you can then you
can get those talks going they seem very
very uh wide apart at the at the moment
but you know there's always some hope
and perhaps there is a way but no acaps
will be through thrilled at this they do
a lot of individual mediation with
people now but they're you know they are
there for the biggies as well
um but but like many other sectors the
doctors have made it clear this is not
just about pay it's recognition for how
hard their life is and um you know in a
sense the government keeps saying well
we know what an amazing job you do etc
etc but um you know the the fact that
they're losing people the retention of
Junior doctors surely once again must
drive people to think about making them
an offer to end this strike action Noah
yeah I think fundamentally it is an
issue about pay and and the matter of um
conditions in terms of crumbling
hospitals ridiculously long hours uh
comes secondary to that but I think this
issue of uh doctors moving overseas to
countries like New Zealand Australia uh
to work where there is a better
lifestyle for them is something that's
very worrying and that the government
really needs to sit down the Department
of Health and think about the 35 percent
uh pay rise that Junior doctors are
asking for is really really unlikely to
happen and really
quite unaffordable for the treasury I
mean we've just had the IMF saying today
that uh UK debt is going uh sorry that's
um the pay rise is going to Fan the
Flames of inflation
um and that UK debt is growing
um and that is all very concerning and
you know raising public sector pay in
such a significant way could be very
damaging to that so I think but I don't
think the junior doctors expect to get a
35 pay rise either that's sort of the
starting point they're gonna have to
meet somewhere in the middle because as
we've seen with uh the likes of the rmt
Union other public sector of other
unions um they haven't given up they've
kept going so the government's going to
have to compromise at some point but
finding that middle spot is going to be
very difficult yes there is a and there
is that yeah that Britain the NHS has uh
spent decades
um stealing doctors from developing
countries instead of training our own
and now we're in danger of losing those
we train to to other countries but you
go back to the nursing dispute and I
remember the line from Steve Bartley the
health secretary was no extra money this
year it's got to be the independent pay
review body you'll have to wait and then
he completely u-turned on it uh now it's
probably better who's going to U-turn
again to do it sooner rather than later
and avert some of the industrial action
and more people being added to a record
where he list already over over 7
million and I think now nowhere in the
junior doctors are you know a right No
One's Gonna expect them to get 35 this
year but you need a Workforce plan for
the NHS and that requires filling the
vacancies training that people and you
also need some scheme on pay to attract
and retain and motivate staff uh right
across the board But it includes doctors
who I think have a have a very good case
at their pay has just been hugely eroded
over the years and all of a sudden we're
now in a crisis as a result yes I was
just going to add from what Noah was
saying about the IMF suggesting that the
debt to GDP ratio is heading quite
swiftly to a hundred percent
um you know quite a change from pre the
financial crisis certainly
um in uh within five years I think they
said so just to pick up what you were
saying I remember the Tories David
Cameron and George Ogle and were going
bonkers when it was a fraction of that
under labor in 2010. I think it was in
the 40s wasn't it anyway
um just very quickly uh no other final
story in the Daily Telegraph we're going
to look at is that the change or the
shake-up of how police deal with crime
we heard yesterday stats from London a
mobile phone disappearing every six
minutes suggestion that Rouse with
neighbors and Twitter spats will no
longer be recorded as offenses
I think this will be welcomed by a lot
of people who care far more about you
know a really expensive and important
item like your mobile phone being stolen
then spats on Twitter I mean I get loads
of Twitter abuse all the time
um and it's not pleasant but there are
so much more important things that
police should be focusing on such as
this issue of mobile phones which
effectively feels like it's been theft
of mobile phones feels like it's been
decriminalized in London you know if
your phone gets stolen or even if
something an item like a laptop gets
stolen from your house you're really
lucky if the police are going to do
anything about it so these much more
minor issues like spats like social
media trolls I think there should be way
more focus on these important issues
that have a much more profound effect on
the day-to-day lives of people before we
then even look at those much more lower
issues